you might have heard the term paying
yourself first and this just means put
your safety your needs especially your
future needs first before you think
about other things so let's give
ourselves an example let's say that you
want to buy a laptop that is
624 and you currently do not have the
624 dollars to buy that laptop and that
laptop will help you with your work
maybe it'll help you with school or can
help your family in some way it can also
provide other benefits that you want so
you want your future self to have this
laptop and you say I want this laptop
over the course of the next year so you
want this in a year the paying yourself
first philosophy would say all right
every paycheck how much do I have to put
aside first before I do anything else to
make sure that I'm gonna get my hands on
this laptop
so let's have an example let's say that
I'm paid weekly if we are paid weekly
how much do we have to put aside for
every paycheck in order to at the end of
the year have 624 dollars saved up for
the laptop
well if we're thinking weekly we have to
save that
624 dollars over the number of weeks in
a year so we're going to divide that by
52 weeks and you could do that by hand
or you could punch that into a
calculator and you're going to say
you're going to see that you're going to
have to save 12 per week which doesn't
feel like a lot and so what you would do
is every time you get that paycheck
before you even think about anything
else you would take that twelve dollars
and transfer it maybe into a savings
account that's kind of your
laptop savings fund what if you instead
of getting paid weekly you're paid by
weekly
so that means you're getting paid every
other week or every two weeks well then
you're going to have to save twice as
much since it's going it's not covering
just one week of savings it's two weeks
of savings so in that situation it's
going to be twenty four dollars per
every two weeks
what if you are being paid
semi-monthly and you might think that
these are similar that if you're paid
every other week or if you're paid
semi-monthly which means you're paid
twice a month but months don't have
exactly four weeks or at least most
months don't have exactly four weeks and
so the way that you would calculate for
semi monthly is you say all right
there's 12 months in a year so there's
24 semi months in a year so it would be
six hundred and twenty four dollars
divided by those 24 semi months I guess
you could call them and then that would
get you twenty six dollars
twenty six dollars per
semi month
semi
month and then last but not least if
you're paid monthly and I'll do that in
a different color for kicks if you're
paid monthly well then you're going to
take that 624 dollars and divide it by
the 12 months
and you would want to set aside fifty
two dollars
fifty two dollars per month
so this video gave us a little bit of
practice thinking about our paychecks
whether we're getting paid weekly
bi-weekly semi-monthly or monthly but
it's really thinking about hey you have
a pretty big goal over here but if you
divide it by the number of paychecks
that you're getting in a year you can
then think about how much you have to
set aside paying yourself first every
paycheck so that it will add up over the
course of a year whatever time period
you're thinking about so that you can
get and reach your goal